durchbruch bei der grundrente monatelang
haben union und spd gestritten jetzt
gibt es einen kompromiss vierte wahl in
knapp vier jahren wieder stimmen die
spanier über ein neues parlament ab und
wieder droht ein patt und sandro schwarz
muss gehen nach der achten
saisonniederlage trennt sich mainz 05
von seinem cheftrainer
nachrichten sich das heute mit christian
sievers einen guten sonntagabend in
allen willkommen bei uns um 7 sport
nachher mit rudi cerne hallo guten amt
lange streit
heute einigung die koalition hat jetzt
ein kompromiss bei der grundrente es
geht darum denen besser zu helfen die im
alter wenig geld haben weil sie nur eine
kleine rente bekommen und das obwohl sie
lange eingezahlt haben
der große knackpunkt war die frage wie
geprüft werden soll
wer in frage kommt die lösung jetzt es
wird aufs einkommen geguckt da wird
gebaut
nach monatelangem koalitionsstreit und
weiteren sechseinhalb stunden
verhandlungen heute die einigung
geringverdiener die mindestens 35 jahre
gearbeitet haben bekommen einen renten
auf schlag nach langen verhandlungen
dicken knoten geschlagen in dieser
koalition und ein schwieriges thema
angegangen deutschland wird eine
grundrente bekommen und das ist ein
sozialpolitischer meilenstein
das ist etwas worauf wir lange
hingearbeitet haben statt einer
sogenannten bedürftigkeitsprüfung bei
der etwa auch vermögens und
eigentumswerte geprüft worden wären soll
es nun eine umfassende einkommensprüfung
geben dabei soll ein freibetrag in höhe
von 1250 euro für alleinstehende und von
1950 euro für paare bis zu 1 5 millionen
menschen sollen profitieren
was wir jetzt auf den weg gebrachte mass
ein echtes gerechtigkeit und
leistungspaket zusammen
gleichzeitig will die koalition die
beiträge zur arbeitslosenversicherung
leicht senken und zukunftstechnologien
fördern die opposition vom gesamtpaket
nicht überzeugt es ist so dass von den
ursprünglich geplanten über drei
millionen jetzt nicht einmal die hälfte
anspruchsberechtigte bleibt und das geht
überhaupt nicht in ordnung das ist ein
klassischer schlechter kuhhandel weil
die union ein schlechtes modell der spd
dauerhaft geschluckt hat bis zu 15
milliarden euro könnte die grundrente
jährlich kosten
und zum ersten januar 2021 kommen
noch eine kurze anordnung dazu live aus
berlin abendmahl strich drunter nach
einem langen streit kann man sagen wer
sich durchgesetzt hat und ich glaube
beide seiten werden die teile der
vereinbarung für sich reklamieren auch
um es dann in den nächsten tagen den
fraktionen und parteien durchsetzen zu
können
die union wird sicher unter anderem den
zusätzlichen zehn milliarden fonds für
zukunftstechnologien betonen und auch
die wenn auch nur vorübergehende
absenkung des beitrags zur
arbeitslosenversicherung beides der
wirtschaftsfreundliche maßnahmen und die
maximal forderung der spd ist halbiert
worden statt drei millionen menschen
sind jetzt geschätzt nur maximal 1,5
millionen anspruchsberechtigt aber
dennoch gilt meines erachtens relativ
klar die spd hat sich stärker
durchgesetzt sie hat den kreis der
anspruchsberechtigten aus dem gemeinsam
beschlossenen koalitionsvertrag damals
geschätzt weniger als 150.000 menschen
glatt verzehnfacht sagt theo koll in
berlin herzlichen dank damit es unserem
nächsten thema heute abend die spanier
können noch eine knappe stunde lang zur
wahl gehen was sie nicht unbedingt
begeistert denn es ist schon die zweite
wahl in diesem jahr nötig ist die
parlamentswahl aber in jedem fall der
ministerpräsident pedro sanchez hat es
nicht geschafft eine stabile regierung
zu bilden
die frage ist allerdings ob das nach
dieser wahl klappt aus madrid thomas
walde um 18 uhr haben alle wahlbüros wie
dieses in madrid gemeldet wie viele
wähler schon an die urnen gegangen sind
das ergebnis fast vier prozentpunkte
weniger als beim letzten mal
viele wähler mussten sich offenbar neu
motivieren
eigentlich habe ich keine lust schon
wieder zu wählen aber das müssen wir als
linke weil die rechte der zeit so
aggressiv ist
die parteien müssen sich jetzt einigen
damit es mal weiter geht und dieses hin
und her aufhört es muss eine regierung
geben
dieses mal wird es klappen so oder so er
hofft dass es diesmal für ihn klappt
pedro sanchez hat beim letzten mal die
meisten stimmen bekommen aber keine
mehrheit im parlament zustande gebracht
wir wählen jetzt und dann sehen wir uns
das ergebnis an und dann regieren wir
spanien braucht definitiv stabilität
sanchez schloss allerdings eine große
koalition aus ebenso wie sein
konservativer gegenkandidat pablo casado
aber dass wir können jetzt wählen
zwischen weiter so und verenden und
gambio in barcelona randalierten in der
nacht einige unabhängigkeit aktivisten
aber die massiv verstärkte polizei
hinziehen schafft die eskalation in
katalonien wird laut umfragen der
extremen rechten mehr stimmen bescheren
als bei der letzten wahl in bolivien
haben sie wochenlang gegen die
wiederwahl von staatspräsident evo
morales protestiert jetzt offenbar die
entscheidende wende morales hat eine
neue abstimmung angekündigt kurz zuvor
waren internationale wahlbeobachter zu
dem schluss gekommen dass bei der wahl
von morales tatsächlich getrickst wurde
mehr von thomas concia danke ruft sie
danke umarmung applaus für die
sicherheitskräfte
es ist der moment in dem sie sich den
protesten anschließen die polizei als
freund und helfer sprechgesang brandet
auf widerstand widerstand gegen
präsident morales der gibt dem druck nun
nach kündigt neuwahlen an er wolle den
sozialen zusammenhalt und die einheit
boliviens bewahren
die proteste immer größer gewalttätiger
wurden sie seit morales umstrittener
wiederwahl von betrug sprechen
beobachter und die opposition bei der
neuwahl sollte kormoran ist gar nicht
mehr als kandidat antreten
bilder aus zeiten als ihnen noch der
jubel galt fast 14 jahre langes morales
an der macht seine tage als präsident
könnte nun gezählt sein
zurück nach deutschland gegen rassismus
und antisemitismus stellt sich die
evangelische kirche in deutschland
sie hat ihrer synode in dresden begonnen
und der ratsvorsitzende heinrich bedford
strohm sagte parteien disqualifizierten
sich in der demokratischen
auseinandersetzung wenn sie
rechtsradikale ideen in ihren reihen
duldet rassismus im alltag müsse man
aktiv entgegentreten
nebel und glatteis und eine
massenkarambolage auf der autobahn 7 in
unterfranken
der fahrer eines kleintransporters hatte
die kontrolle über sein fahrzeug
verloren
die autofahrer hinter ihm konnten nicht
mehr rechtzeitig bremsen
insgesamt krachten 18 autos ineinander
29 menschen wurden verletzt vier mussten
ins krankenhaus
und für erfreulicheres haben wir jetzt
ja und wieder muss ein trainer gehen
fußball bundesligist mainz 05 trennt
sich von trainer sandro schwarz nach dem
2 3 gegen aufsteiger union berlin der
achten saison niederlage zieht die
vereinsführung die konsequenzen und
sucht einen nachfolger mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit aber auch so dass es
ein auswärtiger trainer sozusagen auch
wird denn eine gewisse erfahrung
mitbringt einfach um diese jetzige
situation auch zu beleuchten und auch
mit seiner ganzen erfahrung einfach auch
der mannschaft weiterhilft borussia
mönchengladbach macht es sich an der
tabellenspitze der fußball-bundesliga
immer bequemer nach dem 3 1 erfolg gegen
werder bremen beträgt der vorsprung auf
die verfolger nun vier punkte wolfsburg
setzt den abwärtstrend fort dritte
niederlage innerhalb einer woche
unterliegt leverkusen zu hause mit 0 2
gold silber und ein weltrekord die
deutschen parallel stadt lebten haben
bei der wm in dubai ein beeindruckendes
auftakt wochenende hingelegt
schon kurz nachdem er im 100 meter
vorlauf
überquert hat johannes los ist zu wissen
neuer weltrekord um 10,54 sekunden
ich habe irgendwie die zeit gesehen und
muss sie einfach gern auf ghana
weltrekord im kugelstoßen der
kleinwüchsigen erreicht titelverteidiger
nico kappelt schon im zweiten versuch
seine beste weite und wird mit 13 meter
87 zweiter hinter dem usbeken amon oft
noch ein deutscher höhepunkt dann am
abend als leon schäfer im weitsprung
gleich im ersten versuch der größte satz
gelingt auf sechs meter 90 und damit zum
zweiten gold für das deutsche team und
die deutsche frauenfußball
nationalmannschaft setzte gestern abend
ein ausrufezeichen im legendären
londoner wembley stadion vor der
traumkulisse von 77.000 768 zuschauern
entscheidet die 18-jährige klarer bühl
das packende prestige-duell in letzter
minute mit dem 2 1 siegtreffer
nie zuvor hatten deutschlands und
england spielerinnen vor derart vielen
fans erspielt große bühne christian
absolute die vielen dank dann können wir
alle gemeinsam noch aufs wetter gucken
morgen zunächst teils sonnig teils
länger neblig trüb im westen nachmittags
etwas regen es wird nicht wärmer als 4
bis 9 grad
und so bleibt auch in den nächsten tagen
viele wolken wenig sonne tut mir leid
claus kleber hat das heute journal um
21.45 mit einem gespräch zum kompromiss
in sachen grundrente der
bundesfinanzminister ist da morgen freut
sich hier petra gerster auf sie vom
gesamten team der heute 19 uhr sendung
danke fürs interesse und in ein
angenehmer abend zum beispiel mit berlin
direkt und schackenthal banerjee hallo
dollar